when we were little anyway black holes
were just kind of a figment of
Einstein's imagination there are
consequence of his general theory of
relativity but it wasn't until we had
observations that people realize these
things actually happen when you draw a
black hole what you're basically drawing
is not the black hole itself but the
boundary of the black hole called the
event horizon and inside this boundary
is basically not a part of our universe
as we discovered there are two kinds of
black holes there are black holes that
have masses a few times the mass of the
Sun and the other kind that we know that
exists are called super massive black
holes these are a million or more times
the mass of the Sun so the ways you
observe these two different kinds of
black holes are slightly different we
use ground-based telescopes that or to
watch the star orbiting around the black
hole and we've set up a telescope system
in Chile using some of Yale's telescopes
we call this the smartes telescopes for
this purpose to watch the companion
stars and the material begin its journey
down to the black hole as the stuff
falls onto the black hole it heats up
and emits much more energetic radiation
and that we observe with NASA's orbiting
observatories for the supermassive black
holes we use the Yale Keck telescope to
study the galaxies surrounding the black
holes so that we can try to discern
whether there are visible effects on the
stars and the material in the galaxies
from this this active black hole is
accreting at the center of the galaxy
material falling onto the black hole
forms a disk so it's orbiting the black
hole in a disk and it needs to slowly
lose energy physics students will know
it needs to lose angular momentum before
it can fall in and what happens in the
supermassive black hole case which is
really important for Fermi is that
matter flowing in some of it goes into
the black hole but some of it shoots out
in sort of energetic Jets of particles
that are flowing out in both directions
very narrow very highly collimated Jets
that flow out in both directions and
they're moving at nearly the speed of
light so it's a tremendous amount of
energy and we don't actually understand
the accretion process well enough to
know how how the material going in is
collimated and formed into these
energetic Jets and that's one of the
mysteries that Fermi is going to help us
with and the one of the things that
we're observing most intensely here at
Yale is a category of these black holes
called blazars blazers happen when this
jet of material comes straight at you so
we're down here here's our eyeball or
our Observatory and the jet moving in a
large fraction of the speed of light is
coming straight at us and so that
provides some of the most energetic
radiation you can observe over the whole
universe there are lots of these things
and they're pointing different ways you
know there's a jet pointing that way
there's one pointing this way there's a
bunch that are not pointing at us so
we're not special but the one that point
is pointing at us there's an effect of
special relativity in other Weinstein's
theories that makes it a thousand times
brighter than it would otherwise be so
the ones where you want to study the
chip in the accretion process those are
the blades ours and those are what Fermi
detects and so shortly after the launch
of Fermi when the Fermi team released
its first picture of the whole sky what
we discovered was that a particular one
of these things which was not well
studied before or particularly
thought to be special happened to be
very very energetic it was very
brightest object in the gamma-ray sky
this hitherto relatively anonymous
object and so we turned all of our
telescopes to watch this exciting object
as this black hole presumably accreted a
big lump of matter and shot it back out
at us and made a bright light bulb yeah
for the for the specialists they go by
funny names I think it's interesting to
just say 3c4 we don't call them you know
Charles or Meg we call them some strange
number from a catalogue 3c4 54.3 but
every astronomer knows what that means
and they know what the subject is and we
want to understand how a creating matter
gets energized by the black hole and how
it gets ejected at these speeds and so
by studying these blazed ours we hope to
answer those questions
there are two things that matter okay we
get in light okay all of it is light
what matters is the wavelength of the
light and how bright it is as a function
of time we refer in lights often as
photons which are packets of light so we
might ask how many photons do we get as
a function of time
I mean astronomers per second photons
per second so we might draw a plot that
looks at the intensity of an object a
black hole let's say a blazer as a
function of time and we quite frequently
see variations where it gets bright and
then it gets dim and in all manners in
between and the the beauty of the
research we're doing here at Yale using
the smartes telescopes and the Fermi
Space Telescope gamma-ray Space
Telescope is that we can look at this
light curve in the optical at optical
wavelengths these are wavelengths this
is the light your eye sees and then we
can plot the gamma-ray light curve at
the same time and we'll see that it more
or less follows the same trajectory and
the new stuff over the past couple of
years is that for the first time we're
able to get a light curve like this of
intensity versus time in the optical and
in the gamma rays at the same time for
the same objects that's what the
combination of the Fermi satellite and
our telescopes in Chile can do and so
for the first time we've been able to
confirm that they do go up and down
together and that it turns out rules out
a whole bunch of different theories
about what might be going on and
confirms some other ones and the exact
details of how these Wiggles line up is
what we're working on now and that's
going to give us a whole bunch of
details about exactly what's going on in
this jet as stuff is shot out of a black
hole at close to the speed of light
these Blazers are very happy millions of
light-years away or half a universal
grapha universe away and they're
emitting you know billions of photons in
all directions and we get a few hundred
or a few thousand a piddling amount we
can figure out what's actually what the
physics is in this object that's it's
amazing team
you